[Musique]
ce soit en olivier rousteing qui est
avec lui hier
je suis content d'être là parce que
généralement je regarde tes poèmes puis
quand je rentre chez moi au replay alors
j'ai vu que tu rentrais tard le soir et
étaient souvent seul
souvent j'ai vu tu manges tout seul sans
le voilà dans le dock tout ça mais je
suis jamais seul parce que je suis avec
vous en fait c'est vrai regardez thème
était un autre truc que tu kiff
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ça ça te met de bonne humeur mais ça
ça me met des courriers colis vraiment
bien j'ai des potes qui voulait dire
bonjour
[Musique]
m6 avec 7
[Applaudissements]
les vendeurs croient que ces schémas
tu te par peggy nash ôter l'encré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'étais invitée d'un des fils r je suis
tanné des années je suis venu moi pas
loupé à fait vrai je me rappelle si tu
vas aimer à côté d'un garçon qui
travaille toi ajouté le directeur
général qui est numéro 1 il reste trois
personnes jean-michel max bernat et
maxime il y en a deux qui ont perdu est
un qui est numéro 1 attention qui est
numéro 1 la table va le désigner
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
du facile de couronnes aussi enfin signe
à chaque fois beaucoup de courage mais
j'aime bien c'est frais c'est ce que
vous avez ainsi bout comme ça fait quoi
vous non c'est un copain qui me dit tu
dis je suis avec toi il allait voir sa
maîtresse j'ai décliné le poste à un
classique seulement il a eu un problème
avec la maîtresse au lit c'est à dire
qu'il a eu ce qu'on appelle une verge
brisé un verre brisé ce qu'on appelle
une vb et il a cassé son jouet et donc
il vient me voir et donc je l'emmène à
l'hôpital et tout ça et après on va les
voir ma femme et commentent à une verge
brisé chez moi j'ai dit c'est quand même
compliqué à expliquer c'est le corps
spongieux qui s'est pliée sur
intéressant ça ça arrive quand on
regarde sa partenaire et qu'on veut la
retourner alors je suis on est allé à
prévoir sa femme on a dit qu'il avait
porté une caisse une caisse
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'écoute pas me croire et qu'au dessus
comme ça on est en train de faire les
emplettes à cache pas mais juste
on va faire un délire je vais le mettre
sur mon disque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
petit truc con acapulco la jeunesse vers
djadja non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'adore habitude sachs et 17
il est sexy laisser apparaître que le
dire on retrouve pas dans un sauna avec
moi je t'aime bien faire actelion je
connais yvelines et claude tes parents
et en fait ils sont mariés depuis
combien de temps parce qu'à chaque fois
je les vois dans les concerts de 2,20
sens qui viennent souvent assister à des
concerts était alors non en fait ils
sont divorcés
[Applaudissements]
bavure
ça va toi moi savoir au niveau du
blouson et comment les frais on effraie
toujours j'aime bien tu sais que tu vas
faire avoir des problèmes avec le csa
avec tv là bas ça c'est ton problème
[Rires]
t'inquiète pas tu inquiète pas pour ton
anniversaire était prévu un truc away ne
crois pas que tu vas partir comme ça il
ya deux jours deux jours les 26 c'est
mieux que toi tu t'es con ce mec
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et tu sais qu'il est lourd ce sont trois
ans d'absence durant lesquels tu es
devenu père d'une petite fille croft
comment s'appelle moyens c'est vrai
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'avais mal et bien pâle et blanches et
les petites robes ma passion star wars à
votre vocabulaire des je suis ton jeu
suivant
[Rires]
[Musique]
lula
khan et d'autres termes il ya quelques
années
et son camion
[Applaudissements]